how's it going to and everybody again
San Diego comic-con starts Thursday a
lot of new exciting things will be
happening so be sure to subscribe to my
channel if you'd like to stay up to date
with comic-con just a couple days away
Entertainment Weekly has released a
special issue with Shazam on the cover
right now there is a lot of hype around
DC Justice League was not received very
well by the fans which is a bummer
because Wonder Woman was such a great
movie justice league was supposed to be
the movie that brought the DC EU back
but unfortunately it didn't do that
however it did cause them to reevaluate
their movies that in turn made them take
a completely different approach to the
movies that they're putting out they're
getting away from the dark tones that
were in the other DC EU movies which i
think is a really good thing and it's no
coincidence that they're highlighting
Shazam for their special issue Shazam is
supposed to be a light-hearted funny and
comedic superhero he's a
fourteen-year-old kid who can turn into
a superhero by saying a single word and
that's what this cover is really getting
at
he's blowing a bubble he's got a cell
phone in his hands everything is really
bright it's just a big change from how
DC normally does things this is meant to
be brighter it's meant to be more
lighthearted and less serious and I
think it does a good job and they even
have a little description of the
superhero in the bottom right that says
by saying the magic word
fourteen-year-old Billy Batson
transforms into a superhero who can do
almost anything except break his curfew
and not to mention the way that they
released this photo was pretty funny and
light-hearted as well Zachary Levi on
Twitter today tweeted at Entertainment
Weekly saying hey a TW big fan so this
Comic Con issue I know it's like days
away from dropping but is there any
chance I can get on the cover how do we
make this happen
asking for a friend who was too
embarrassed to ask for me Entertainment
Weekly replied with just say the magic
word in which is a curry Levi said um
please and Entertainment Weekly replied
with we were thinking something more
like Shazam
but okay here you go
payment Wiggly then of course dropped
the cover for their latest comic-con
special issue and Zachary Levi replied
with ha really that feels a little on
the nose but if holy it worked and that
cover is dope thank you for this and for
our completely impromptu and not plans
at all exchange Zachary Levi is super
stoked to play the character in an
interview he said it's complete wish
fulfillment if you scour all of DC and
Marvel there are very few characters
that are actually stoked to be a
superhero they're not brooding they're
not put out like oh dang it I gotta save
the world again Billy Batson is like
Peter Parker they're thrilled to have
these powers and can't wait to try them
out producer Peter sanfran also chimed
in and gave his opinion from my
perspective
Shazam represents the next step in the
evolution of the DC brand you had Wonder
Woman
then Aquaman is another big step then
comes Shazam all different movies but
all have a unique tone that moves away
from the darkness of the prior DC movies
so as you can tell they're taking a
completely different approach to how
they make their movies now and I think
it's really good that they're taking a
step back from all of the dark tones
that they've had in the other movies we
know that we're going to be getting our
first trailer for Aquaman this Saturday
however we're unsure just how much
spotlight Shazam will be given but
seeing as how he's on the cover of
Entertainment Weekly special comic-con
issue I think there's some exciting
things to come
I personally am very much looking
forward to a light-hearted comedic
superhero movie from DC so what do you
think about this new cover and what do
you think about the new direction that
DC is taking hit me with your thoughts
in the comments below like this video
and again we'll be covering comic-con
all weekend so be sure to subscribe to
my channel so you can stay up to date
thank you all so much for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]
[Music]